rugbyman le soir commercial le jour
ludovic de manille fait partie des 160
employés sélectionnés par l'entreprise
véolia pour participer aux rencontres
mondiales de sport d'entreprise à
athènes sa discipline le rugby à 7
toutes les entreprises qui veulent
inscrire des sportifs qui sont dans leur
entreprise quel que soit le sport il ya
plein de sports il ya du tir à l'arc du
basket du foot du hand du beach volley
du rugby à 7 on est 160 sportive veolia
à partir athènes ce sportif qui va fêter
ses 45 ans la semaine prochaine à 35
années de rugby derrière lui trois ans
d'ancienneté dans l'entreprise c'est via
filiale de veolia qu'il a sélectionnés
pour participer spécialisé dans le
traitement des huiles de vidange usagers
et la gestion des déchets spéciaux elle
participe à la compétition depuis
plusieurs années c'est veolia qui envoie
tous les quatre ans une délégation sur
différents sports parce que le format
des mondiaux c'est c'est un format jeux
olympiques en fait donc j'ai rempli le
formulaire en fait c'est un espèce de
recrutement sur cv en fait donc ce long
parcours sportif
donc j'ai été contacté pour pour être
sélectionné participer à cette belle
aventure au total huit français et trois
anglais font partie de l'équipe ils ne
se sont jamais rencontrés mais vont tous
représentez l'entreprise dans
l'entreprise on fait partie d'un groupe
d'une équipe ce qui peut ce qui peut
être retranscrit
aujourd'hui chez ces viard il fait
partie de partie d'une entreprise on
c'est un travail d'équipé je pense qu'il
est très
très serviable très cohésion d'équipé et
je pense que ça c'est une qualité pour
le sport surtout quand on fait un sport
collectif et tout le monde compte sur
lui même si voilà les années passent ces
on reste toujours compétiteurs donc je
vais pas là-bas pour faire le touriste
c'est si on peut ramener quelque chose
ça serait avec grand plaisir et grande
fierté ah bah il n'a pas le choix il
faut qu'ils nous rapportent quelque
chose